The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu
PROFESSOR: OK, if you have not
yet done it, please take a
moment to go through the course
evaluation website and
enter your comments
for the class.
So what we're going to do today
to wrap things up is
we're going to go through
a tour of the world of
hypothesis testing.
See a few examples of hypothesis
tests, starting
from simple ones such as the
one the setting that we
discussed last time in which you
just have two hypotheses,
you're trying to choose
between them.
But also look at more
complicated situations in
which you have one
basic hypothesis.
Let's say that you have a fair
coin and you want to test it
against the hypotheses that
your coin is not fair, but
that alternative hypothesis is
really lots of different
hypothesis.
So is my coin fair?
Is my die fair?
Do I have the correct
distribution for random
variable, and so on.
And I'm going to end up with a
few general comments about
this whole business.
So the sad thing in simple
hypothesis testing problems is
the following--
we have two possible models,
and this is the classical
world so we do not have any
prior probabilities on the two
hypotheses.
Usually we want to think of
these hypotheses as not being
completely symmetrical, but
rather one is the default
hypothesis, and usually it's
referred to as the null
hypothesis.
And you want to check whether
the null hypothesis is true,
whether things are normal as you
would have expected them
to be, or whether it turns out
to be false, in which case an
alternative hypothesis
would be correct.
So how does one go about it?
No matter what approach you use,
in the end you're going
to end up doing the following.
You have the space of all simple
observations that you
may obtain.
So when you do the experiment
you're going to get an X
vector, a vector of data
that's somewhere.
And for some vectors you're
going to decide that you
accept H. Note for some vectors
that you reject H0 and
you accept H1.
So what you will end up doing
is that you're going to have
some division of the space of
all X's into two parts, and
one part is the rejection
region, and one part is the
acceptance region.
So if you fall in here you
accept H0, if you fall here
you'd reject H0.
So to design a hypothesis test
basically you need to come up
with a division of your X
space into two pieces.
So the figuring out how to do
this involves two elements.
One element is to decide what
kind of shape so I want for my
dividing curve?
And having chosen the shape of
the dividing curve, where
exactly do I put it?
So if you were to cut this
space using, let's say, a
straight cut you might put it
here, or you might put it
there, or you might
put it there.
Where exactly are you
going to put it?
So let's look at those
two steps.
The first issue is to decide
the general shape of your
rejection region, which is the
structure of your test.
And the way this is done for the
case of two hypothesis is
by writing down the likelihood
ratio between the two
hypothesis.
So let's call that quantity l of
X. It's something that you
can compute given the
data that you have.
A high value of l of X basically
means that this
probability here tends to be
bigger than this probability.
It means that the data that you
have seen are quite likely
to have occurred under H1,
but less likely to have
occurred under H0.
So if you see data that they
are more plausible, can be
better explained, under H1, then
this ratio is big, and
you're going to choose in favor
of H1 or reject H0.
That's what you do if you
have discrete data.
You use the PMFs.
If you have densities, in the
case of continues data, again
you consider the ratio
of the two densities.
So a big l of X is evidence
that your data are more
compatible with H1
rather than H0.
Once you accept this kind of
structure then your decision
is really made in terms
of that single number.
That is, you had your data that
was some kind of vector,
and you condense your data
into a single number-- a
statistic as it's called--
in this case the likelihood
ratio, and you put the
dividing point somewhere
here call it Xi.
And in this region you
accept H1, in this
region you accept H0.
So by committing ourselves to
using the likelihood ratio in
order to carry out the test
we have gone from this
complicated picture of finding a
dividing line in x-space, to
a simpler problem of just
finding a dividing point on
the real line.
OK, how are we going?
So what's left to do is to
choose this threshold, Xi.
Or as it's called, the
critical value,
for making our decision.
And you can place it anywhere,
but one way of deciding where
to place it is the following--
look at the distribution of this
random variable, l of X.
It's has a certain distribution
under H0, and it
has some other distribution
under H1.
If I put my threshold here,
here's what's going to happen.
When H0 is true, there is this
much probability that I'm
going to end up making an
incorrect decision.
If H0 is true there's still a
probability that my likelihood
ratio will be bigger than Xi,
and that's the probability of
making an incorrect decision
of this particular type.
That is of making a false
rejection of H0.
Usually one sets this
probability to a certain
number, alpha.
For example alpha being 5 %.
And once you decide that you
want this to be 5 %, that
determines where this number
Psi(Xi) is going to be.
So the idea here is that I'm
going to reject H0 if the data
that I have seen are quite
incompatible with H0.
if they're quite unlikely to
have occurred under H0.
And I take this level, 5%.
So I see my data and then I say
well if H0 was true, the
probability that I would have
seen data of this kind would
be less than 5 %.
Given that I saw those data,
that suggests that H0 is not
true, and I end up
rejecting H0.
Now of course there's the
other type of error
probability.
If I put my threshold here, if
H1 is true but my likelihood
ratio falls here I'm going
to make a mistake of
the opposite kind.
H1 is true, but my likelihood
ratio turned out to be small,
and I decided in favor of H0.
This is an error of the other
kind, this probability of
error we call beta.
And you can see that
there's a trade-off
between alpha and beta.
If you move your threshold this
way alpha become smaller,
but beta becomes larger.
And the general picture is, in
your trade-off, depending on
where you put your threshold
is as follows--
you can make this beta to be 0
if you put your threshold out
here, but in that case you are
certain that you're going to
make a mistake of the
opposite kind.
So beta equals 0, alpha equals
1 is one possibility.
Beta equals 1 alpha equals 0
is the other possibility if
you send your thresholds
complete to the other side.
And in general you're going
to get a trade-off
curve of some sort.
And if you want to use a
specific value of alpha, for
example alpha being 0.05, then
that's going to determine for
you the probability for beta.
Now there's a general, and quite
important theorem in
statistics, which were
are not proving.
And which tells us that when we
use likelihood ratio tests
we get the best possible
trade-off curve.
You could think of other ways
of making your decisions.
Other ways of cutting off your
x-space into a rejection and
acceptance region.
But any other way that you do
it is going to end up with
some probabilities of error
that are going to be above
this particular curve.
So the likelihood ratio test
turns out to give you the best
possible way of dealing
with this trade-off
between alpha and beta.
We cannot minimize alpha and
beta simultaneously, there's a
trade-off between them.
But at least we would like to
have a test that deals with
this trade-off in the
best possible way.
For a given value of alpha we
want to have the smallest
possible value of beta.
And as the theorem is that the
likelihood ratio tests do have
this optimality property.
For a given value of alpha they
minimize the probability
of error of a different kind.
So let's make all these concrete
and look at the
simple example.
We have two normal
distributions
with different means.
So under H0 you have
a mean of 0.
Under H1 you have a mean of 1.
You get your data, you actually
get several data
drawn from one of the
two distributions.
And you want to make a
decision, which one
of the two is true?
So what you do is you write
down the likelihood ratio.
The density for a vector of
data, if that vector was
generated according to H0 --
which is this one, and the
density if it was generated
according to H1.
Since we have multiple data the
density of a vector is the
product of the densities of
the individual elements.
Since we're dealing with
normals we have those
exponential factors.
A product of exponentials
gives us an
exponential of the sum.
I'll spare you the details, but
this is the form of the
likelihood ratio.
The likelihood ratio test
tells us that we should
calculate this quantity after we
get your data, and compare
with a threshold.
Now you can do some algebra
here, and simplify.
And by tracing down the
inequalities you're taking
logarithms of both
sides, and so on.
One comes to the conclusion that
using a test that has a
threshold on this ratio is
equivalent to calculating this
quantity, and comparing
it with a threshold.
Basically this quantity here is
monotonic in that quantity.
This being larger than the
threshold is equivalent to
this being larger than
the threshold.
So this tells us the general
structure of the likelihood
ratio test in this
particular case.
And it's nice because it tells
us that we can make our
decisions by looking at this
simple summary of the data.
This quantity, this summary of
the data on the basis of which
we make our decision is
called a statistic.
So you take your data, which is
a multi-dimensional vector,
and you condense it to a single
number, and then you
make a decision on the
basis of that number.
So this is the structure
of the test.
If I get a large sum of Xi's
this is evidence in favor of
H1 because here the
mean is larger.
And so I'm going to decide in
favor of H1 or reject H0 if
the sum is bigger than
the threshold.
How do I choose my threshold?
Well I would like to choose
my threshold so that the
probability of an incorrect
decision when H0 is true the
probability of a false
rejection equals
to a certain number.
Alpha, such as for
example 5 %.
So you're given here
that this is 5 %.
You know the distribution
of this random
variable, it's normal.
And you want to find the
threshold value that makes
this to be true.
So this is a type of problem
that you have
seen several times.
You go to the normal tables,
and you figure it out.
So the sum of the Xi's has some
distribution, it's normal.
So that's the distribution
of the sum of the Xi's.
And you want this probability
here to be alpha.
For this to happen what is the
threshold value that makes
this to be true?
So you know how to solve
problems of this kind using
the normal tables.
A slightly different example is
one in which you have two
normal distributions that
have the same mean --
let's take it to be 0 --
but they have a different
variance.
So it's sort of natural that
here, if your X's that you see
are kind of big on either side
you would choose H1.
If your X's are near 0 then
that's evidence for the
smaller variance you
would choose H0.
So to proceed formally you again
write down to the form
of the likelihood ratio.
So again the density of an X
vector under H0 is this one.
It's the product of
the densities of
each one of the Xi's.
Product of normal densities
gives you a product of
exponentials, which is
exponential of the sum, and
that's the expression
that you get.
Under the other hypothesis
the only thing that
changes is the variance.
And the variance, in the normal
distribution, shows up
here in the denominator
of the exponent.
So you put it there.
So this is the general structure
of the likelihood
ratio test.
And now you do some algebra.
These terms are constants
comparing this ratio to a
constant is the same as just
comparing the ratio of the
exponentials to a constant.
Then you take logarithms, you
want to compare the logarithm
of this thing to a constant.
You do a little bit of algebra,
and in the end you
find that the structure of the
test is to reject H0 if the
sum of the squares of the Xi's
is bigger than the threshold.
So by committing to a likelihood
ratio test you are
told that you should be making
it your decision according to
a rule of this type.
So this fixes the shape or the
structure of the decision
region, of the rejection
region.
And the only thing that's left,
once more, is to pick
this threshold in order to have
the property that the
probability of a false rejection
is equal to say 5 %.
So that's the probability that
H0 is true, but the sum of the
squares accidentally
happens to be
bigger than my threshold.
In which case I end
up deciding H1.
How do I find the value
of Xi prime?
Well what I need to do is to
look at the picture, more or
less of this kind, but now
I need to look at the
distribution of the sum
of the Xi's squared.
Actually the sum of the Xi's
squared is a non-negative
random variable.
So it's going to have a
distribution that's
something like this.
I look at that distribution, and
once more I want this tail
probability to be alpha, and
that determines where my
threshold is going to be.
So that's again a simple
exercise provided that you
know the distribution
of this quantity.
Do you know it?
Well we don't really know it,
we have not dealt with this
particular distribution
in this class.
But in principle you should be
able to find what it is.
It's a derived distribution
problem.
You know the distribution
of Xi, it's normal.
Therefore, by solving a derived
distribution problem
you can find the distribution
of Xi squared.
And the Xi squared's are
independent of each other,
because the Xi's are
independent.
So you want to find the
distribution of the sum of
random variables with
known distributions.
And since they're independent,
in principle, you can do this
using the convolution formula.
So in principle, and if you're
patient enough, you will be
able to find the distribution
of this random variable.
And then you plot it or tabulate
it, and find where
exactly is the 95th percentile
of that distribution, and that
determines your threshold.
So this distribution actually
turns out to have a nice and
simple closed-form formula.
Because this is a pretty common
test, people have
tabulated that distribution.
It's called the chi-square
distribution.
There's tables available
for it.
And you look up in the tables,
you find the 95th percentile
of the distribution,
and this way you
determine your threshold.
So what's the moral
of the story?
The structure of the likelihood
ratio test tells
you what kind of decision region
you're going to have.
It tells you that for this
particular test you should be
using the sum of the Xi
squared's as your statistic,
as the basis for making
your decision.
And then you need to solve a
derived distribution problem
to find the probability
distribution of your statistic.
Find the distribution of this
quantity under H0, and
finally, based on that
distribution, after you have
derived it, then determine
your threshold.
So now let's move
on to a somewhat
more complicated situation.
You have a coin, and you
are told that I tried
to make a fair coin.
Is it fair?
So you have the hypothesis,
which is the default--
the null hypothesis--
that the coin is fair.
But maybe it isn't.
So you have the alternative
hypothesis that
your coin is not fair.
Now what's different in this
context is that your
alternative hypothesis is not
just one specific hypothesis.
Your alternative hypothesis
consists of many alternatives.
It includes the hypothesis
that p is 0.6.
that p is 0.51.
It includes the hypothesis that
p is 0.48, and so on.
So you're testing this
hypothesis versus all this
family of alternative
hypothesis.
What you will end up doing is
essentially the following--
you get some data.
That is, you flip the coin
a number of times.
Let's say you flip
it 1,000 times.
You observe some outcome.
Let's say you saw 472 heads.
And you ask the question if
this hypothesis is true is
this value really possible
under that hypothesis?
Or would it be very much
of an outlier?
If it looks like an extreme
outlier under this hypothesis
then I reject it, and I accept
the alternative.
If this number turns out to be
something within the range
that you would have expected
then you keep, or accept your
null hypothesis.
OK so what does it mean to
be an outlier or not?
First you take your data,
and you condense
them to a single number.
So your detailed data actually
would have been a sequence of
heads/tails, heads/tails
and all that.
Any reasonable person would tell
you that you shouldn't
really care about the exact
sequence of heads and tails.
Let's just base our decision on
the number of heads that we
have observed.
So using some kind of reasoning
which could be
mathematical, or intuitive,
or involving artistry--
you pick a one-dimensional, or
scalar summary of the data
that you have seen.
In this case, the summary of the
data is just the number of
heads that's a quite
reasonable one.
And so you commit yourself to
make a decision on the basis
of this quantity.
And you ask the quantity that
I'm seeing does it look like
an outlier?
Or does it look more
or less OK?
OK, what does it mean
to be an outlier?
You want to choose the shape of
this rejection region, but
on the basis of that
single number s.
And again, the reasonable thing
to do in this context
would be to argue as follows--
if my coin is fair I expect to
see n over 2 heads.
That's the expected value.
If the number of heads I see
is far from the expected
number of heads then I consider
this to be an outlier.
So if this number is bigger
than some threshold Xi.
I consider it to be an outlier,
and then I'm going to
reject my hypothesis.
So we picked our statistic.
We picked the general form of
how we're going to make our
decision, and then we pick a
certain significance, or
confidence level that we want.
Again, this famous 5% number.
And we're going to declare
something to be an outlier if
it lies in the region
that has 5% or less
probability of occurring.
That is I'm picking my rejection
region so that if H0
is true under the default, or
null hypothesis, there's only
5% chance that by accident I
fall there, and the thing
makes me think that H1
is going to be true.
So now what's left to
do is to pick the
value of this threshold.
This is a calculation
of the usual kind.
I want to pick my threshold,
my Xi number so that the
probability that s is further
from the mean by an amount of
Xi is less than 5%.
Or that the probability
of being inside
the acceptance region--
so that the distance
from the default is
less than my threshold.
I want that to be 95%.
So this is an equality that you
can get using the central
limit theorem and the
normal tables.
There's 95% probability that the
number of heads is going
to be within 31 from
the correct mean.
So the way the exercise is done
of course, is that we
start with this number, 5%.
Which translates to
this number 95%.
And once we have fixed that
number then you ask the
question what number should
we have here to make this
equality to be true?
It's again a problem
of this kind.
You have a quantity whose
distribution you know.
Why do you know it?
The number of heads by the
central limit theorem is
approximately normal.
So this here talks about the
normal distribution.
You set your alpha to be 5%, and
you ask where should I put
my threshold so that this
probability of being out there
is only 5%?
Now in our particular example
the threshold
turned out to be 31.
This number turned out
was just 28 away
from the correct mean.
So these distance was less
than the threshold.
So we end up not rejecting H0.
So we have our rejection
region.
The way we designed it is that
when H0 is true there's only a
small chance, 5%, that we get
to data out of there.
Data that we would
call an outlier.
If we see such an outlier
we reject H0.
If what we see is not an outlier
as in this case, where
that distance turned out to
be kind of small, then we
do not reject H0.
An interesting little piece
of language here, people
generally prefer to use
this terminology--
to say that H0 is not rejected
by the data.
Instead of saying that
H0 is accepted.
In some sense they're both
saying the same thing, but the
difference is sort of subtle.
When I say not rejected what I
mean is that I got some data
that are compatible with
my hypothesis.
That is the data that I got do
not falsify the hypothesis
that I had, my null
hypothesis.
So my null hypothesis is still
alive, and may be true.
But from data you can never
really prove that the
hypothesis is correct.
Perhaps my coin is not fair in
some other complicated way.
Perhaps I was just lucky, and
even though my coin is not
fair I ended up with
an outcome that
suggests that it's fair.
Perhaps my coin flips are
not independent as I
assumed in my model.
So there's many ways that my
null hypothesis could be
wrong, and still I got data
that tells me that my
hypothesis is OK.
So this is the general way that
things work in science.
One comes up with a
model or a theory.
This is the default theory, and
we work with that theory
trying to find whether
there are examples
that violate the theory.
If you find data and examples
that violate the theory your
theory is falsified, and you
need to look for a new one.
But when you have your theory,
really no amount of data can
prove that your theory
is correct.
So we have the default theory
that the speed of light is
constant as long as we do not
find any data that runs
counter to it.
We stay with that theory, but
there's no way of really
proving this, no matter how
many experiments we do.
But there could be experiments
that falsify that theory, in
which case we need to do
look for a new one.
So there's a bit of an asymmetry
here in how we treat
the alternative hypothesis.
H0 is the default which we'll
accept until we see some
evidence to the contrary.
And if we see some evidence to
the contrary we reject it.
As long as we do not see
evidence to the contrary then
we keep working with it,
but always take it
with a grain of salt.
You can never really prove that
a coin has a bias exactly
equal to 1/2.
Maybe the bias is equal
to 0.50001, so
the bias is not 1/2.
But with an experiment with
1,000 coin tosses you wouldn't
be able to see this effect.
OK, so that's how you go about
testing about whether your
coin is fair.
You can also think about testing
whether a die is fair.
So for a die the null hypothesis
would be that every
possible result when you roll
the die has equal probability
and equal to 1/6.
And you also make the hypothesis
that your die rolls
are statistically independent
from each other.
So I take my die, I roll it a
number of times, little n, and
I count how many 1's I got, how
many 2's I got, how many
3's I got, and these
are my data.
I count how many times I
observed a specific result in
my die roll that was
equal to sum i.
And now I ask the question--
the Ni's that I observed, are
they compatible with my
hypothesis or not?
What does compatible to
my hypothesis mean?
Under the null hypothesis Ni
should be approximately equal,
or is equal in expectation
to N times little Pi.
And in our example this little
Pi is of course 1/6.
So if my die is fair the number
of ones I expect to see
is equal to the number
of rolls times 1/6.
The number of 2's I expect to
see is again that same number.
Of course there's randomness,
so I do not expect to get
exactly that number.
But I can ask how far
away from the
expected values was i?
If my capital Ni's turn to be
very different from N/6 this
is evidence that my
die is not fair.
If those numbers turn out to be
close to N times 1/6 then
I'm going to say there's no
evidence that would lead me to
reject this hypothesis.
So this hypothesis
remains alive.
So someone has come up with this
thought that maybe the
right statistic to use, or the
right way of quantifying how
far away are the Ni's from
their mean is to
look at this quantity.
So I'm looking at the expected
value of Ni under the null
hypothesis.
See what I got, take the square
of this, and add it
over all i's.
But also throw in these terms
in the denominator.
And why that term is there,
that's a longer story.
One can write down certain
likelihood ratios, do certain
Taylor Series approximations,
and there's a Heuristic
argument that justifies why this
would be a good form for
the test to use.
So there's a certain art that's
involved in this step
that some people somehow decided
that it's a reasonable
thing to do is to calcelate.
Once you get your results to
calculate this one-dimensional
summary of your result, this is
going to be your statistic,
and compare that statistic
to a threshold.
And that's how you make
your decision.
So by this point we have fixed
the type of the rejection
region that we're
going to have.
So we've chosen the qualitative
structure of our
test, and the only thing that's
now left is to choose
the particular threshold
we're going to use.
And the recipe, once
more, is the same.
We want to set our threshold so
that the probability of a
false rejection is 5%.
We want the probability that our
data fall in here is only
5% when the null hypothesis
is true.
So that's the same as setting
our threshold Xi so that the
probability that our
test statistic is
bigger than that threshold.
We want that probability
to be only 0.05.
So to solve a problem of
this kind what is it
that you need to do?
You need to find the probability
distribution of
capital T. So once more
it's the same picture.
You need to do some calculations
of some sort, and
come up with the distribution
of the random variable T,
where T is defined this way.
You want to find this
distribution
under hypothesis H0.
Once you find what that
distribution is then you can
solve this usual problem.
I want this probability
here to be 5%.
What should my threshold be?
So what does this
boil down to?
Finding the distribution of
capital T is in some sense a
messy, difficult, derived
distribution problem.
From this model we know
the distribution
of the capital Ni's.
And actually we can even write
down the joint distribution of
the capital Ni's.
In fact we can make an
approximation here.
Capital Ni is a binomial
random variable.
Let's say the number of 1's that
I got in little N rolls
off my die.
So that's a binomial
random variable.
When little n is big
this is going to be
approximately normal.
So we have normal random
variables, or approximately
normal minus a constant.
They're still approximately
normal.
We take the squares of these,
scale them so you can solve a
derived distribution problem
to find the distribution of
this quantity.
You can do more work, more
derived distribution work, and
find the distribution of
capital T. So this is a
tedious matter, but because this
test is used quite often,
again people have done
those calculations.
They have found the distribution
of capital T, and
it's available in tables.
And you go to those tables, and
you find the appropriate
threshold for making a decision
of this type.
Now to give you a sense of how
complicated hypothesis one
might have to deal with let's
make things one level more
complicated.
So here you can think this X is
a discrete random variable.
This is the outcome
of my roll.
And I had a model in which the
possible values of my discrete
random variables they
have probabilities
all equal to 1/6.
So my null hypothesis here was
a particular PMF for the
random variable capital X. So
another way of phrasing what
happened in this
problem was the
question is my PMF correct?
So this is the PMF of the
result of one die roll.
You're asking the question
is my PMF correct?
Make it more complicated.
How about the question of the
type is my PDF correct when I
have continuous data?
So I have hypothesized that's
the probability distribution
that I have is let's say
a particular normal.
I get lots of results from
that random variable.
Can I tell whether my results
look like normal or not?
What are some ways of
going about it?
Well, we saw in the previous
slide that there is a
methodology for deciding
if your PMF is correct.
So you could take your normal
results, the data that you got
from your experiment, and
discretize them, and so now
you're dealing with
discrete data.
And sort of used in previous
methodology to solve a
discrete problem of the type
is my PDF correct?
So in practice the way this is
done is that you get all your
data, let's say data points
of this kind.
You split your space into bins,
and you count how many
you have in each bin.
So you get this, and that,
and that, and nothing.
So that's a histogram that
you get from the
data that you have.
Like the very familiar
histograms that you see after
each one of our quizzes.
So if you look at these
histogram, and you ask does it
look like normal?
OK, we need a systematic
way of going about it.
If it were normal you can
calculate the probability of
falling in this interval.
The probability of falling in
that interval, probability of
falling into that interval.
So you would have expected
values of how many results, or
data points, you would have
in this interval.
And compare these expected
values for each interval with
the actual ones that
you observed.
And then take the sum of
squares, and so on, exactly as
in the previous slide.
And this gives you a way
of going about it.
This is a little messy.
It gets hard to do because you
have the difficult decision of
how do you choose
the bin size?
If you take your bins to be very
narrow you would get lots
of bins with 0's, and a few
bins that only have one
outcome in them.
It probably wouldn't
feel right.
If you choose your bins to be
very wide then you're losing a
lot of information.
Is there some way of making a
test without creating bins?
This is just to illustrate
the clever ideas of what
statisticians have
thought about.
And here's a really cute way of
going about a test, whether
my distribution is
correct or not.
Here we're essentially
plotting a PMF, or an
approximation of a PDF.
And we ask does it look like
the PDF we assumed?
Instead of working with PDFs
let's work with cumulative
distribution functions.
So how does this go?
The true normal distribution
that I have hypothesized, the
density that I'm hypothesizing--
my null
hypothesis--
has a certain CDF
that I can plot.
So supposed that my hypothesis
H0 is that the X's are normal
with our standard normals, and I
plot the CDF of the standard
normal, which is the sort of
continuous looking curve here.
Now I get my data, and I
plot the empirical CDF.
What's the empirical CDF?
In the empirical CDF you ask the
question what fraction of
the data fell below 0?
You get a number.
What fraction of my
data fell below 1?
I get a number.
What fraction of my data fell
below 2, and so on.
So you're talking about
fractions of the data that
fell below each particular
number.
And by plotting those fractions
as a function of
this number you get something
that looks like a CDF.
And it's the CDF suggested
by the data.
Now the fraction of the data
that fall below 0 in my
experiment is--
if my hypothesis were true--
expected to be 1/2.
1/2 is the value of
the true CDF.
I look at the fraction
that I got, it's
expected to be that number.
But there's randomness, so
it's might be a little
different than that.
For any particular value, the
fraction that I got below a
certain number--
the fraction of data that
we're below, 2, its
expectation is the probability
of falling below 2, which is
the correct CDF.
So if my hypothesis is true the
empirical CDF that I get
based on data should, when
n is large, be very
close to the true CDF.
So a way of judging whether my
model is correct or not is to
look at the assumed CDF, the
CDF under hypothesis H0.
Look at the CDF that I
constructed based on the data,
and see whether they're
close enough or not.
And by close enough, I mean I'm
going to look at all the
possible X's, and look at the
maximum distance between those
two curves.
And I'm going to have a test
that decides in favor of H0 if
this distance is small,
and in favor of H1 if
this distance is large.
That still leaves me
the problem of
coming up with a threshold.
Where exactly do I
put my threshold?
Because this test is important
enough, and is used frequently
people have made the effort
to try to understand the
probability distribution
of this quite
difficult random variable.
One needs to do lots of
approximations and clever
calculations, but these have
led to values and tabulated
values for the probability
distribution
of this random variable.
And, for example, those
tabulated values tell us that
if we want 5% false rejection
probability, then our
threshold should be 1.36
divided by the
square root of n.
So we know where to put
our threshold for
this particular value.
If we want this particular
error or error
probability to occur.
So that's about as hard and
sophisticated classical
statistics get.
You want to have tests for
hypotheses that are not so
easy to handle.
People somehow think of
clever ways of doing
tests of this kind.
How to compare the theoretical
predictions with the observed
predictions with the
observed data.
Come up with some measure of the
difference between theory
and data, and if that difference
is big, than you
reject your hypothesis.
OK, of course that's not
the end of the field of
statistics, there's
a lot more.
In some ways, as we kept
moving through today's
lecture, the way that we
constructed those rejection
regions was more and
more ad hoc.
I pulled out of a hat a
particular measure of fit
between data and the model.
And I said let's just use
a test based on this.
There are attempts at more or
less systematic ways of coming
up with the general shape of
rejection regions that have at
least some desirable or
favorable theoretical
properties.
Some more specific problems
that people study--
instead of having a test,
is this the correct PDF?
Yes or no.
I just give you data, and I
ask you tell me, give me a
model or a PDF for those data.
OK, my thoughts of this kind
are of many types.
One general method is you form a
histogram, and then you take
your histogram and plot a smooth
line, that kind of fits
the histogram.
This still leaves the question
of how do you choose the bins?
The bin size in your
histograms.
How narrow do you take them?
And that depends on how many
data you have, and there's a
lot of theory that tells you
about the best way of choosing
the bin sizes, and the best
ways of smoothing the data
that you have.
A completely different topic
is in signal processing --
you want to do your inference.
Not only you want it to be good,
but you also want it to
be fast in a computational
way.
You get data in real
time, lots of data.
You want to keep processing and
revising your estimates
and your decisions as
they come and go.
Another topic that was briefly
touched upon the last couple
of lectures is that when you set
up a model, like a linear
regression model, you choose
some explanatory variables,
and you try to predict y from
your X, these variables.
You have a choice of
what to take as
your explanatory variables.
Are there systematic ways of
picking the right X variables
to try to estimate a Y.
For example should I try to
estimate Y on the basis of X?
Or on the basis of X-squared?
How do I decide between
the two?
Finally, the rage these days has
to do with anything big,
high-demensional.
Complicated models of
complicated things, and tons
and tons of data.
So these days data are
generated everywhere.
The amounts of data
are humongous.
Also, the problems that people
are interested in tend to be
very complicated with
lots of parameters.
So I need specially tailored
methods that can give you good
results, or decent results even
in the face of these huge
amounts of data, and possibly
with computational
constraints.
So with huge amounts of data
you want methods that are
simple, but still can deliver
for you meaningful answers.
Now as I mentioned some time
ago, this whole field of
statistics is very different
from the field of probability.
In some sense all that we're
doing in statistics is
probabilistic calculations.
That's what the theory
kind of does.
But there's a big
element of art.
You saw that we chose the shape
of some decision regions
or rejection regions in
a somewhat ad hoc way.
There's even more
basic things.
How do you organize your data?
How do you think about which
hypotheses you would like to
test, and so on.
There's a lot of art that's
involved here, and there's a
lot that can go wrong.
So I'm going to close with a
note that you can take either
as pessimistic or optimistic.
There is a famous paper that
came out a few years ago and
has been cited about a
1,000 times or so.
And the title of the paper is
Why Most Published Research
Findings Are False.
And it's actually a very good
argument why, in fields like
psychology or the medical
science and all that a lot of
what you see published--
that yes, this drug
has an effect on
that particular disease--
is actually false, because
people do not do their
statistics correctly.
There's lots of biases
in what people do.
I mean an obvious bias is that
you only published a result
when you see something.
So the null hypothesis is that
the drug doesn't work.
You do your tests, the drug
didn't work, OK, you just go
home and cry.
But if by accident that 5%
happens, and even though the
drug doesn't work, you got
some outlier data, and it
seemed to be working.
Then you're excited,
you publish it.
So that's clearly a bias.
That gets results to be
published, even though they do
not have a solid foundation
behind them.
Then there's another
thing, OK?
I'm picking my 5%.
So H0 is true there's a small
probability that the data will
look like an outlier,
and in that case I
published my result.
OK it's only 5% --
it's not going to happen
too often.
But suppose that I go and do
a 1,000 different tests?
Test H0 against this hypothesis,
test H0 against
that hypothesis , test H0
against that hypothesis.
Some of these tests, just by
accident might turn out to be
in favor of H1, and
again these are
selected to be published.
So if you do lots and lots of
tests and in each one you have
a 5% probability of error,
when you consider the
collection of all those tests,
actually the probability of
making incorrect inferences
is a lot more than 5%.
One basic principle in being
systematic about such studies
is that you should first pick
your hypothesis that you're
going to test, then get
your data, and do
your hypothesis testing.
What would be wrong is to get
your data, look at them, and
say OK I'm going now to test
for these 100 different
hypotheses, and I'm going to
choose my hypothesis to be for
features that look abnormal
in my data.
Well, given enough data, you
can always find some
abnormalities just by chance.
And if you choose to make
a statistical test--
is this abnormality present?
Yes, it will be present.
Because you first found the
abnormality, and then you
tested for it.
So that's another way that
things can go wrong.
So the moral of this story is
that while the world of
probability is really beautiful
and solid, you have
your axioms.
Every question has a unique
answer that by now you can,
all of you, find in a
very reliable way.
Statistics is a dirty and
difficult business.
And that's why the subject
is not over.
And if you're interested in
it, it's worth taking
follow-on courses in
that direction.
OK so have good luck in the
final, do well, and have a
nice vacation afterwards.